today on the mat well show we are told
that privilege in this country is
reserved for white people especially
white males white male privilege is the
thing right but I think the real
privilege in our modern culture is
leftist privilege that's how you get the
privilege and I want to talk about why
and provide the evidence for the
existence of leftist privilege
quite a lot of evidence recently also 5
headlines including the mob coming to
cancel cartoon dogs paw patrol is now in
in their sights and Ilhan Omar claims
that she is oppressed despite being one
of the most powerful women in the
country she is oppressed by the very
system that enabled her to rise so
quickly to power and prominence that's
an interesting kind of oppression isn't
it and plus our daily cancellation and
much more all of that on the way but
first a word from ancestry.com you know
learning about your family ancestry
where you come from I think is really
important also it's also is very
interesting I'm a fan of reading about
history and reading about your own
history is one of the most fundamental
and interesting things you can do now
you may be familiar with the major
events and battles of the war of World
War two so many great stories you can
uncover there and the great thing is
that in honor of the 75th anniversary of
the end of World War two ancestry has
just released a u.s. draft card
collection from World War two with over
36 million draft cards completed by
fighting aged men in the United States
across the country during that time
whether they ended up serving or not
there's a great chance that you could
find your relatives in this collection
you can uncover their personal details
in ancestry coms World War 2 US draft
card collection which shows details like
home address physical description and
much more it's just a lot of fun you
know I've done ancestry.com and I found
it to be a really easy process a lot
quicker than I was expecting which was
nice and then it's totally fascinating
when you get all the information and you
see your own family tree sort of unfurl
or sprout in front of you discover your
untold stories and more today head to my
URL at ancestry.com slash mat to start
discovering your story today that's
ancestry.com slash mat ok so over the
last several days protesters have
down statues in many cities across the
country a monument to Columbus was torn
from its base set on fire thrown in a
lake in Virginia a couple days ago we
talked about that yesterday another
statue of Columbus in Minneapolis was
destroyed despite this statue having
been sculpted by an immigrant almost 100
years ago and given as a gift to the
italian-american immigrant community in
Minneapolis they tore that down anyway
several other Columbus statues have been
as the media so knock you asleep it's it
removed hold on a second oh that's
horrifying there was a there was a
spider on my computer I remain calm
though for the purpose of the camera I
remain calm in the face of that spider
that is courage and heroism anyway where
was I yes statues being being torn down
well the media says they're removed that
that's if you if you look at the
headlines they're gonna say that you
know protesters removed a statue no
removing something removing a statue or
monument that's something that a
legitimate Authority can do they can
remove it if it's a mob if it's a
rampaging mob they're not removing
they're tearing down toppling destroying
okay one of those descriptions I think
is better better better captures what's
actually happening Confederate monuments
of course I've been toppled as well
across the country and now the mob has
set its eyes on you know things like the
Washington and Jefferson monument site
the activists are now talking out we got
to take those down to which anybody with
a brain saw this coming and I would just
caution any member of the mob to be
careful felling those monuments
especially when you consider that one
member of the mob in Virginia was
critically injured last night pulling
down a statue because it fell right on
his head and cracked his skull open and
he's I think in critical condition in
hospital lucky to have survived if he
does ultimately survive yet
there's something you know there's
something rather conspicuous missing
especially when you consider actually on
top of the fact that this is a crime
it's also dangerous these are these are
very heavy things that are being torn
down by people who don't necessarily
have expertise in removing large jobs at
objects from spaces like this so there's
something missing in all these videos of
the crazed mobs tearing down statues and
monuments the thing that's missing of
course is besides common sense and
decency and a respect for history and a
respect for property besides all that
the other thing missing is law
enforcement and I know it's kind of a
silly question to ask at this point but
still where are the police
while these vandals destroyed public
property tear down priceless works of
art that have stood in some cases for a
century or more you almost have to
remind yourself while watching this that
you actually don't have the legal right
to do what they're doing the way that
they're able to do it so sort of
casually and it takes time to pull down
a monument it's not just something that
a person can do want to win you've got
to come prepared you've got it you gotta
pull people you've got it you know it
takes time to do and you watch this you
think what where where are the police
I mean you'd be excused for thinking
almost well the public property does
that mean the public can do whatever it
wants with it the answer is no in fact
destruction of property worth more than
five hundred dollars in most states is a
felony these statues are worth way more
than five hundred dollars these statues
are worth thousands hundreds of
thousands of dollars probably in some
cases so these are felony crimes that
were witnessing they are also as I said
dangerous crimes as the man in Virginia
convincingly demonstrated but this has
been the theme in recent weeks the
police stand by while leftist radicals
do quite literally whatever they want in
Seattle now a group of radicals have
seized
control of several city blocks and and
declared it a sovereign state they've
set up checkpoints and barricades
uniformed police are barred from entry
because that's something you can
apparently do now the police in fact
were nice enough in the city to abandon
their precinct at the rioters best which
is a repeat of what we witnessed in
Minneapolis where the the police
abandoned a precinct said in that case
of course the precinct was and ransacked
and set on fire somehow in a civilized
country that was once ruled by law this
has all become a familiar sight mobs
rampaging through our cities setting
buildings on fire destroying police cars
destroying public property the strong
private property throwing bricks
invading government buildings looting
assaulting murder and very little effort
is made to stop any of these crimes from
happening or to punish any of the people
who commit them now there is much
discussion right about privilege in our
culture in fact the concept of privilege
is one of the things fueling these mobs
they're very upset about privilege
they're upset that they would say that
you know someone like me has a lot of
privilege because privilege is bestowed
based on race and gender and I as a
white man have the most privilege of
most privilege of all according to them
yet the interesting thing is that I'm
fairly short I haven't tested this I
admit but I'm fairly sure that if I
drove into town right now and I threw a
brick in a window or I set a retail
outlet on fire or I looted a convenience
store or I invaded a police precinct or
I tried to set up my own autonomous zone
my own sovereign state in the middle of
the street or if I yanked down a statue
or a monument because I found it
personally displeasing I would be
arrested on the spot with very little
fanfare and if I resisted arrest and I
was beaten or even killed by police in
the process even if my death was
store the result of excessive force
there would be no CNN headlines about it
no riots in my honor
no elaborate displays a performative
grief from our elected officials in
Washington
nobody kneeling in in getting in moments
of silence none of that whatever my
white privilige gets me it does not get
me that and it doesn't provide me a pass
that allows me to rampage through the
city stealing destroying looting and
burning so it seems to me that the
greatest privilege on offer in our
culture today is the privilege to be
utterly immune from the law this is the
privilege that is exercised by many of
the protesters and though some of them
are white males many of them are not so
it is then obviously a privilege that is
not dispensed based on race but it is
dispensed based on ideology
this is leftist privilege a person with
the quote correct worldview especially
if he has gathered in a group with other
correct thinking people can do almost
anything he wants now the powers that be
will bend over backwards to accommodate
him and to meet his demands this
includes permitting crime as we have
seen but also much else besides he'll
consider all of the corporations and
brands that have been tripping over each
other to express their support for the
radical left-wing black lives matter
organization and it doesn't always take
a mob to get this kind of capitulation
from our culture's most powerful forces
HBO's streaming service as you've heard
took down Gone with the Wind the classic
film took it out from its platform
because one correct thinking individual
wrote an op-ed instructing them to do so
and so they did this is on the same day
that Webster's dictionary edited its
definition of racism because a young
black woman emailed and said they should
they apparently got one email and said
alright I'll change the definition if
you say so
these are just the most recent examples
of leftist privilege we haven't even
discussed the many extravagant
concessions that the LGBTQ Lobby has
been able to extract including allowing
men access to women's bathrooms locker
rooms sports teams while shaming and
silencing any women who express
discomfort over this invasion of their
privacy any women who have the audacity
to say hey gee you know I'd rather not
have a man right here a leering at me
while I'm getting changed they're gonna
be shamed and silenced the man's gonna
be allowed access to that yeah I would
call that privileged and even though
it's a male it's not exactly male
privilege because not any man can do
that it's only the correct thinking man
it's only the man affiliated with the
LGBTQ Lobby and the man on the left that
is allowed to do that as a white man I
have not really seen doors open for me
or exceptions made for me or advantages
given to me just based on my race it is
obvious that in order to obtain these
privileges I have to demonstrate my
allegiance to the leftist tribe I have
to have the right quote unquote right
views I have to say the right things I
have to hold the right opinions and
beliefs that's how you get the privilege
this is what our culture's most instant
our philosophy a go seize control of
these institutions and privilege is
simply one of the spoils of victory and
it always has been if you're on the
winning side you get the privilege if
you're not you don't this is the result
of decades of the left invading taking
over seizing control of the most
powerful institutions in our culture
what was what what was the right doing
during that time what were conservatives
doing well conservative spent decades of
course ignoring you know the leftist
takeover of education and pop culture
and Hollywood and media
ignoring that and instead focusing on
getting Republicans elected to Congress
so we could pass tax cuts and you know
spread democracy in the Middle East that
was conservatism priorities for decades
really that really worked out didn't it
that worked out really well but that's
how privilege works and that to me seems
pretty obvious now let's move on to
headlines there is now apparently a
backlash brewing against the show paw
Patrol which is a show about Cartoon
Dogs also the show than my
three-year-olds and say every
three-year-old in the country is
obsessed with paw patrol leftist are now
targeting the show because of its
positive portrayal of police now the
police are dogs in this show but you
know that's a problem too apparently and
this in spite of the fact that paw
patrol sent out a tweet a few days ago
bowing at the BLM altar as you are
required to do and expressing their
submission and obedience that is
required of them here's here's a tweet
from paw patrol again this is a this is
a cartoon show about about
crime-fighting dogs and this is what it
says in solidarity of amplify Mellon
ated voices we will be muting our
content until June 7th to give access to
black voices to be heard so we can
continue to listen and further our
learning hashtag amplify black voices
and then there's a black box that says
muted and listening so this is a thing
now where white people or even cartoon
dogs who are honorary white people I
suppose are expected to stop talking so
that black people can talk muted and
listening now how exactly are black
people prevented from talking just
because other people are talking as well
I I don't know this is a country of
three hundred and thirty million people
everybody's talking all the time you're
not going to be the only one talking
doesn't matter what your race is and how
are you persecuted or oppressed by the
fact that not everyone in the country is
shutting up while you talk and a better
question how our black voice is
amplified specifically
by the fact that paw patrols Twitter
account didn't tweet for five days how
does that work well it doesn't work it's
all nonsense of course but this is just
the ritualistic self-flagellation
required by the religion of leftism
according to their high priests and
prophets and even though the cartoon
dogs did their part perform the ritual
you know they're still gonna be
sacrificed because even cartoons cannot
escape also by the way the show's cops
and live PD have both been canceled
why have them be they be canceled
because of its positive depictions of
police so this is the game of course the
left is trying to build a narrative has
built a narrative constructed a
narrative about about you know thug
police who are villainous and violent
and are out you know killing people left
and right that's the narrative and
they're just they're not going to allow
for anything that contradicts that
narrative they they want to make sure
that anytime you see police on TV is
always in a negative context and then
they can turn around and say hey you
know most police are bad how just look
turn on the TV all you're ever gonna see
is bad police clearly most police are
bad what they don't mention is that the
only reason you only see bad police is
because they won't allow you to see
anything else other than that number two
Ilhan Omar was was speaking I believe
this is at a rally in Minneapolis but I
don't really know doesn't matter
anyway this is what she had to say is
that for the last 25 years I have lived
as a black person in this country
I have lived as a mother raising black
children so I do know what it means to
be black in America I know
what our young children go through
because I was an adolescent interfacing
with the police department here in
Minneapolis I know my silence will
contribute to complacency and I know
that none of you fought so hard to get
me elected so that I can cosign on a
system that continues to oppress us you
know it's interesting really
Ilhan Omar is an immigrant woman came to
this country despises this country
despises most of its inhabitants
this is this is a woman just filled with
contempt you can hear it every time she
speaks she hates a lot of people in this
country really hates them and yet as an
immigrant woman a racial minority
quickly rose to a position of power and
prominence
she's only I think what 37 or 38 years
old one of the youngest members of
Congress she achieved that okay to her
credit but the system was set up in such
a way as to make it possible for her to
achieve that and now she turns around
and claims to be oppressed by the very
system that enabled her to get into this
position it's remarkable and also what
is the system you know what are you
talking about you say the system
oppresses what system what system are
you referring to specifically whatever
system there is in this country you as a
member of the federal government and you
as a member of the Democrat Party and
you as a leader of the progressive
movement are not only a part of that
system but you are one of the people
controlling it and yet you are oppressed
by the system even as you control the
system it's again it's a remarkable
claim remarkable in its stupidity
Ilhan Omar her story her life is proof
in itself that America is not systemic
ly racist same for Alexandria Kaiser
Cortes same for Barack Obama
and yet these are the people the people
who the people who disprove systemic
racism just by their story by their
existence are the same ones who are the
loudest ones claiming that systemic
racism exists and and and I know that
you know I get it at any time and I'm
sure that what I'm saying right now this
is gonna be one of those things at Media
Matters polls and they they put it on
Twitter Daily wire host claimed systemic
racism doesn't exist because Ilhan omar
was elected yeah you know what that is
sort of what I claim yeah
IIIi think that's pretty good evidence
pretty good evidence when you've got an
immigrant woman who doesn't even like
America and yet was able to come here
and and very quickly find a position of
power pretty good evidence that there
isn't systemic racism yeah Barack Obama
black man becoming the most powerful man
in the country for eight years you know
came those powerful man country
was was voted in again to be the most
powerful man in the country only let had
to leave it because he was term-limited
pretty good evidence you know it's it's
it's that at least is it's not what you
would expect Lee put it this way if you
didn't know anything about America right
and maybe it came here from another
planet and you landed here and you sat
down with a BLM activist or you know any
leftist activist and you had them
describe America to you and you kept
that in mind and then you went out and
actually looked at what's really
happening in America it would not be at
all what you expected based on what they
tell you you would not expect to go to
the capital of this country and find
people like Ilhan Omar running things
you would not expect that the person who
ran the country the most powerful man in
the country for eight years who just
left office four years ago was a black
man you would not expect that it
it's it's it's not something that would
be predicted by the theory of systemic
racism and yeah so that's that is that
is pretty good pretty good evidence I
think and if it doesn't listen if you
know the ability of someone like
Alexandria Kaiser cartels or Ilhan Omar
to to very easily and quickly become
very powerful people in the government
and culturally both of those things if
that is not at least evidence against
systemic racism what would be evidence
against it and we know this is an
unfallen clam the people who make the
claim it is unfalsifiable there is
nothing there is no evidence that you
could ever present ever that they would
consider evidence against their their
claim and unfalsifiable claims are
illegitimate always if it cannot be
falsified if there is nothing that could
ever falsify it it is not legitimate
[Music]
number three
as mentioned previously gone with the
wind was banned by HBO max but it is now
the top-selling movie on Amazon and this
is this is often what happens the try to
the Streisand effect and all of that
which which is great you know and I see
some people celebrating this some
conservatives saying yeah you see the
people the people aren't on board with
this you get rid of Gone with the Wind
they're gonna go and and and throw their
support behind it
and yeah I appreciate that I think it's
a good sign but when you hear this as
speaking of evidence of things I mean
this is supposed to be evidence of the
silent majority and the silent
conservative majority who they're not on
board with all of us I don't know if the
silent majority exists or not but if it
does I mean shame on us if we are still
in the majority in this country and yet
we're allowing all of this to happen
then that's that's even more shameful on
our part I would say number four Natalie
Portman has come out in favor of
defunding the police very brave stuff
extremely heroic here's what she said on
Instagram she said when I first heard
hashtag to fund the police I have to
admit my first reaction was fear my
whole life
police have made me feel safe that's
exactly the center of my white privilige
the police make me as a white woman feel
safe while my black friends family and
neighbors feel the opposite police make
them feel terror and for good reason
police are the sixth leading cause of
death of black men in this country these
are not isolated incidents they are
patterns and part of the system of over
policing of black Americans reforms have
not worked penny appleís where George
Floyd was murdered is one of the most
progressive police forces in the country
having undergone an extensive anti bias
training I've gone to the age of my life
where where if my gut feels
uncomfortable I take the situation as
wrong but this concept initially made me
uncomfortable because I was wrong
because the system that makes me feel
uncomfortable is wrong okay I don't owe
because this does sorry because the
system that makes me feel comfortable is
wrong look as she's saying if I felt
comfortable with it as a white person
that I would know that it's wrong yes
it's what she's saying that I know my
gut instinct is wrong because I'm white
my god have some self-respect
get a hold of yourself the hell is wrong
with you people well I know because I'm
white I can't trust anything I think I
am just scum I am dirt whatever I think
must be wrong you know of course much of
what she said here is completely wrong
she says that police are the sixth
leading cause of death for black men in
this country that's false not true
I'm here the top six leading causes of
death for black men this country
according to the CDC
heart disease cancer unintentional
injury homicide stroke and diabetes
police are not on the list so that is
simply false totally false she says
these are not isolated incidents they
are George Floyd is an isolated incident
there were nine unarmed black men killed
by police last year in a country of 330
million I would call that an isolated
incident yeah I mean that's that's
almost as isolated as it can get and
then but but you know here's the real
irony here she says that because of her
privilege she is because she is aware of
her privilege she is supporting defund
the police but know that that is a very
privileged point of view she is an
extremely wealthy woman living in a very
rich neighborhood I you know with with
I'm assuming a gated community
she can afford personal security I
guarantee she has personal security when
she goes out and about so she's not
gonna be affected by this you want to
talk about privilege you as a rich
person who can afford around-the-clock
24-hour personal security very few
people can afford that you can so you as
a rich person saying yeah let's to fund
the police let's take the police out of
these poor communities so that so that
you mothers and families are gonna have
nobody to call in the event of them
being victims of crime you want to talk
about privileged that's the privileged
perspective if you want to defy your
privilege or or you know take a position
contrary to your privilege then you
would say that
hey listen even though I'm rich and I
can afford personal security I know most
people can't and so that's why I support
the police because by and large in the
vast majority of cases they are
protecting people black white or
otherwise and I think that poor people
in these communities deserve to be
protected they deserve to have law
enforcement they shouldn't be you know I
I don't want to see these communities
burned to the ground and in the grips of
chaos and anarchy I don't want to see it
even though even though it doesn't
affect me because I'm rich I don't want
to see it so if you're really cared
about seeing past your privilege that
would be the position you would take
five finally speaking of Instagram white
influencers on the site are showing
their solidarity of black lives matter
by posting black face photos of
themselves surprisingly noted Instagram
influencer or Ralph Northam has yet to
join this trend but here's one
and here's here's this one that was
posted and the the caption says I wish I
was black today more than ever sending
my love and full support to the people
who demand equality and justice for all
races anywhere in the world
hashtag no justice no peace hashtag
George Floyd hashtag black lives matter
hashtag us a hashtag police-state
hashtag white supremacy hashtag amurica
hashtag justice hashtag peace hashtag
love hashtag cover color hashtag race
hashtag black hashtag strange fruits and
then she's got that I did that picture
there I don't know if that's a black
face photo of her or it's just another
photo that she found if somebody else
maybe it's not black face I don't know
but I wish I was black today more than
ever
shockingly this this did not resonate
and that again is the great irony that
all of these pathetic white people
self-flagellating and expressing their
self-loathing and talking about how
horrible they are and everything it
doesn't it's it almost always backfires
okay finally let's go to our daily
cancelation before we do that you know
there's so much going on in the news
this year hard to know where to even
begin and trying to sort through all of
it and then of course you have the
left-wing media constantly lying about
it and pushing their agenda you can't
trust them I mean speaking of that the
the the radicals the insurrectionists in
Seattle that have set up their own
sovereign state in the middle of a city
taken over city blocks this is basically
not being reported by the mainstream
media there's very little about it now
compare that to what happened when you
had some armed militiamen right-wingers
and where was it an organ you know a few
years ago they took over some
uninhabited plot of land in the middle
of nowhere nobody was around the media
freaked out the left freaked out and now
you've got insurrections in the middle
of a city taking it over and there's
nothing so that's just an example of
left-wing bias and it's why you can't
expect to get the real story from the
left-wing media you have to go outside
the narrative and get the facts so if
your political junkies set on getting
both sides of the story get a reader's
pass today from daily wire calm you'll
get access to exclusive op-eds from us
your podcasts as well as guest writers
in-depth analysis from our daily wire
reporters on top of our regular breaking
news a lot of really interesting stuff
this membership tiers already a bargain
at $3 a month but if you join today and
get your first month you'll get that for
99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app and receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as you can join
the community of daily wire members who
are actively commenting and discussing
our content with each other that's
mobile ad free access to all of our
daily wire news exclusive op-eds and
more on our mobile app all for the low
price of one dollar
of all your dollars are getting you the
news you need without the left is spin
so head over to Delhi wire Khan /
subscribe and join today speaking of
other podcast I also wanted to mention
that Michael Knowles is going to be on
with steven crowder tonight so make sure
you tune tune in ladder with Crowder to
watch that now finally with our daily
cancellation today this is gonna be just
a quick one I I'm gonna be cancelling
the Democratic Party now may seem a
little obvious for me to be canceling
the Democrats that's after all all I
ever do on this show basically every
single day but this is different I'm
canceling them in the spirit of today
the spirit of this moment in our culture
as mobs are going around tearing down
statues and monuments that they perceive
to be monuments to racism relics of our
racist past past well then they should
join me in on that note they should join
me in canceling the Democrat Party
because there is no greater relic or
more powerful relic or monument to our
racist past than the Democrat Party
itself now I know that this is a point
that is very often made which is why I
don't need to dwell on it but I do feel
like it it it should be made again in a
situation like this this is kind of the
at least among Democrats it's the
elephant in the room as we're going
around tearing down Confederate
monuments and Democrats are cheering at
all Democrats are the ones doing it well
we should mention that all of those
Confederates were all Democrats and you
know Nancy Pelosi I think yesterday came
out and said they're all the Confederate
soldier monuments in DC need to come
down she wants to see those taken down
immediately okay well you've been in
office for I think approximately 650
years you've been in office for 650
years or there
bounce close enough a long time and
you're just now getting offended over
these monuments you had all that time to
be offended and to say let's take him
down and just now you're getting
offended right so it's all it's all
performative and fake anyway by as we
know but even still the Democrat Party
is the party of racism it's the party of
Jim Crow it's a party of segregation ISM
it's a party that the party that opposed
equal rights all that's a fact now you
could try to claim that it's they've
changed their ways and it's very
different and you know basically the
Democrat Party and Republican party
switched places at some point somehow
not exactly explaining how that worked
but that's what you can claim it's not
like that anymore now I think that's
wrong actually I think the Democrat
Party still is victimizing minority
communities supporting for example
abortion which as we've discussed this
week has wiped out
many millions of minorities the abortion
industry which especially targets poor
communities which are very often
minority communities so I you know I I
don't think the Democrat Party when it
comes to racism and when it comes to
retrieve minorities I don't think
they've changed that much actually but
whether they have or not a statue statue
is not hurting anybody
it's not like the statue is out actively
oppressing anyone so it's not enough to
say that other Democrat party that
they're not like that anymore they're
not they're not actively harming
minorities now again I think that I
think they are but even if they aren't
well the statue is not harming anyone
either just a statue so this is all
about tearing down based on history
based on something's history what it's
rooted in then I think you cannot exempt
the Democrat Party Democrat Party should
be canceled porn down you know if the
left wants to make a new political party
but the Democrat Party I think it's its
history of racism is just too too
offensive too traumatic and should be
on those grounds so I trust that in this
cancellation the left will join me if
they really mean what they say which of
course means that they won't be joining
me at all but I thought I'd try and
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]